and good to see you again nice to see
you um
uh so i watched i watched this last
night i laughed a lot um and i think
that the chemistry between all four of
you is so good when did you realize that
okay wait this is going to be really
good we're all getting along
from the i think from the moment we got
to puerto rico we started the movie in
puerto rico we then moved to atlanta uh
the pandemic happened in between but
when
when you're put in such a beautiful
setting
we had a resort all to ourselves and
when we weren't in the resort
that belonged to us pretty much we were
bar hopping in puerto rico
and everybody was just having a good
time and it's a movie about
vacation like
with a bunch of people who enjoy
leaning into comedy and leaning into the
uncomfortable and trying to make it
funny like
that's a really good recipe for at the
very least having a good time
and you know i think that's a lot of
what showed in the chemistry now um
the underlying fact is we shot right up
until the world shut down and our last
production day in puerto rico is like
the last production day for anybody and
then we were one of the first
productions back up and running so not
only did we have this like summer camp
bond in puerto rico where we were just
with each other going to these exotic
locations we were also the first people
that we saw
going back into work so it's like yo i
haven't seen or interacted with anyone
let me you know expel my life and what
you know this has been like for me and
we've all shared those stories and
shared those moments and i think that's
a lot of what
the the chemistry can be attributed to
is the time we had to just kind of bond
with each other
uh one of the things about this is that
the film does a really good job of
balancing the crazy with characters that
have heart uh can you sort of talk about
like that line if you will
yeah i think that i think comedy good
comedy does that well
it's it's uh
taking instances that either are too
uncomfortable to talk about or that we
all are familiar with
and then taking them to the extreme
if you're dealing with
someone going to the bathroom
it's it's going to be taken to the
extreme and then we get to laugh at it
and that's the comedy if we're dealing
with someone with no cell service
it's going to be taken to the extreme
and that's why we laugh at it that's it
just that's i think that's what comedy
does well
and
storytelling has to involve heart you
can't just do a bunch of jokes for the
sake of a bunch of jokes i think the the
memorable movies do have a sense of
connection in the sense of
heart and storytelling and
take the audience on a ride and i think
vacation friends does both
i i agree um talk a little bit about
filming that uh the the drug trip if you
will in the forest because
there's been a lot of those kind of
sequences in movies and i enjoyed this
one um maybe it's the beastie boys maybe
it was just the way it was filmed or you
guys but it's a fun scene that's kind of
how clay described it he's like i listen
i know this is going to seem repetitive
and weird
but have you ever seen any of the
the beastie boys check your head stuff
like that's kind of what we're going for
that vibey fisheye lens
what you want type
and uh you know rel and i are both a fan
of hip hop and we kind of got that so
we was just in a forest in atlanta and
we he was just like i just need you to
laugh a lot and go crazy a lot and
kind of lean into it and we both did and
and you're right it's a it that's the
vibe we were going for so i'm glad you
got that out of it
uh what is it actually like filming like
the montage of you guys partying from
bar to bar because those montages
obviously it's like you know it's a
minute of screen time but it's
definitely a lot more than that when it
comes to filming it was really cool
because i got to see a bunch of
locations in puerto rico like that was
really really fun uh and i think it was
fun for everybody so
it's not like you're setting up a big
action sequence you're partying and
drinking and doing some crazy stuff
and
the down time is just
us at a bar
and every one of the cast members
nobody's um tremendously recluse or
secluded or privatized as a human being
everybody is
good with people and i think it was a
perfect cast in the perfect environment
to just enjoy the process and and it
made it really really fun
i'm not mistaken uh you're going to be
working with matthew vaughn in the
not-so-distant future um correct i am a
big fan of matthew vaughn so
what can you tease about this upcoming
film which has a lot of awesome people
in it
well if you look at what matthew vaughn
does with properties and you look at how
um
he stages things and i love how he tells
stories as well i love how he he he sets
the table to tell a wonderful tale and
also
uh
takes things to the extreme but at the
same
at the same token has characters with
heart
uh i know this was recently acquired by
apple and i know matthew's vision for
the whole scope of everything
so
uh
he's gonna do what he does and he's very
capable of what he does and i think this
is the first
of many things you'll see from the
argyle umbrella and that that's that's
my hope i just um i really look forward
to working with him and i think
what he has on the page has such
tremendous potential and i know he's
gonna bring it to life uh in a way
that's gonna entertain us all and i
really look forward to doing more when
do you leave for london to film when are
you making it
that is
it's all classified i can tell you this
i can tell you i will be at uh
summerslam for the wwe on august 21st
and i will also be in madison square
garden for the wwe on september 10th
so
the the stuff around that is completely
classified but i'll i can tell you those
things
got it what are you actually thinking
about you've actually been working on
some really cool stuff recently what are
you looking at for the future and is
after matthew vaughn are you looking at
certain scripts certain roles or is it
i'm always man i'm always reading and uh
i want to i want to work with good folks
but i also want to work with stuff that
is within my skill set but kind of
pushes me and challenges me a little bit
and i don't know what that's going to be
until i read it
so i continuously read scripts and if
i'm moved by one it doesn't i'm not i'm
not looking for like i want this role or
i want
this franchise or something like that it
could be the smallest part
in a story that i find interesting
and i would want to do it that's um
i really just enjoy entertaining and i
really enjoy getting lost in the
material
and uh
i
i just want to be able to do
work that i enjoy doing every day i
don't ever want such a job a job where i
get to play dress up to be a burden
so a good
litmus test for me is to read the
material and like it first
and i think that's why you see such a
wide range of stuff from big action
franchise to
inside the crazy mind of james gunn to a
vacation friends comedy to a matthew
vaughn type
a movie that you'll see and be
wonderfully excited with but it has its
own its own style and its own narrative
um
it's just because i like the stories man
so i really do like the stories congrats
on this thank you for making me laugh
and i cannot wait to talk to you about
peacemaker in january that'll be fun